- I am really feeling the bearded vibe
I love a beard on a man.
- Beard is new for me.
- It is?
- Yeah new and beard.
- Is it for work? Or for life?
- I grew it for work, but now it's
for life because it serves two purposes
I'm loosing a lot of the
elasticity in my jaw,
(crowd laughs)
and also it's like having
a pet on your face.
(crowd laughs)
- (laughs) You just could pet it.
- Never alone. I'm never alone.
- What do your kids think of your beard?
- They're amused and
bemused by everything I do.
- (laughs)
- They just think I'm old.
- That and mine too, it's
super fun when you work hard.
(laughs) So you play a
cool dad in "Indebted",
- Yeah very laid back.
- But tell us about the show
for people that don't know.
- The show is basically the line is,
"baby boomers who go bust,"
and they gotta move in with their kids.
And so Fran Drescher and I play
amazingly good looking grandparents,
- (laughs)
(crowd applauds)
Yes you do.
- Don't applaud.
- (laughs)
- And through years of crazy spending
and bad investments we
move in with our kids.
I'm having a great time cause
my character is like a little
bit of a Lebowski type.
- I love that.
- He likes his special chocolates and
he's really crazy in love with her.
- Oh my gosh.
- So he's relaxing, but the parents
have to parent the parents.
- Yeah, that does happen in
life, but here's my question.
They're rebooting everything,
why not reboot "Wings"?
(crowd applauds)
Cause I loved "Wings".
(crowd cheers)
I mean literally they're
rebooting everything.
- I'd do it, most
everybody became gainfully
employed after "Wings", Tim Daly
is the handsomest man in North America.
- (laughs)
- Still. And Tony Shalhoub,
Amy Yasbeck, Crystal Bernard,
David Schramm, Tom Haden Church.
- It was such a great cast.
- It was a great cast, great show.
- Great chemistry.
- Great chemistry and we had so much fun,
but I'm finally back on a great sitcom.
- And you like the chemistry
of this one too ya?
- They're great. Well I've known Fran
for a long time, so it's
fun to work with her
we're both from...
- I've known her since
"The Nanny" (laughs)
- And then I found out "The Nanny"
is a global event, okay. We went
to these TV kind of sales.
- Comic-con kind of thing?
- It was like a Sony thing right.
- Oh okay.
- So there were TV affiliates from
all over the world, zoom they saw her,
people from Tokyo,
people from Middle East,
and it was great.
- Mr. Sheffield
Yes, yes. (crowd laughs)
- Yes.
- I watched it religiously, yes.
- Apparently you did,
yeah. That's an uncanny...
- "Wings" as well I'm just saying,
- Thanks, thanks.
- This is crazy, you've been in more
than a hundred different shows and movies.
- Wow.
- That's crazy!
(crowd applauds)
- What a career!
- Yes!
That's awesome! Do you remember
your first performance? It doesn't
have to be professional,
just first performance.
- My first performance. So I was in
the third grade and we adapted
the book "Where the Wild Things Are,"
Maurice Sendak, Max goes to the island,
and I managed to land the supporting
role of the dragon, who can be seen on
page three as Max goes,
- (laughs)
- and that was it. I wasn't
the lead, so I guess I
felt compelled to start
ad-libbing profusely.
- You felt competitive.
_ I felt competitive. I just felt
not as intense as the connection
I feel with this audience.
This beautiful audience.
(crowd cheers)
- Good answer! Good answer.
(crowd applauds)
- And I started ad-libbing as the dragon
and people started laughing, and
it was like a shot, and that was the end.
Or the beginning!
- Oh, you liked it, you were like
"that's cool! Like making people laugh."
- That was it, and at some point when
people didn't respond
to a particular scene
I said cut! You know, I was like seven.
(crowd laughs)
And I was getting laughs.
- That's amazing! To know that early.
Wow. What a blessing.
Well one of your first
acting jobs was actually dubbing cartoons?
- Not dubbing cartoons,
but dubbing foreign films.
When I was growing up, on TV they
would have these gladiator films,
or speed racer cartoons,
right speed racer.
So I got a job dubbing
voices in foreign films,
and if you don't know what dubbing is,
and we do it in American
TV and movies too,
if the sound is bad you gotta go into
a studio and then redo the sentence.
For instance, let's do it now.
- Okay, let's do it. Oh I like
it, it's a game, I'm in, Yes!
That's my energy.
(crowd laughs)
- So excited. So contagious.
- Yeah, sorry.
(crowd laughs)
- Now just say this line, say the line
"Melvin, I have to de-vein
the shrimp," just say it.
- Melvin I have to de-vein the shrimp.
- Now I heard a sound, so we have to
take that out, you have to
- Move my mouth.
- Yeah, but it's in another language,
so I have to find the line to fit
the same kind of mouth flaps,
(crowd laughs)
but I have to put in a line that's
germane to whatever film I'm trying to...
- So like, if I'm gonna mouth that...
- Say Melvin, what did you have to say?
- Melvin I have to de-vein the shrimp.
- Okay, so now don't do any voice now.
- Okay.
- Beep, beep, beep, there's a monster in
- (laughs)
(crowd laughs)
- Listen.
- (laughs) I wasn't ready for the...
- You're a terrible beeper.
(crowd laughs)
- I wasn't ready for the
voice change and all of it.
I wasn't ready.
- I just have to approximate
your character, your whole...
- That's amazingly hard.
- Let's do it again.
- I can't look at you.
(crowd laughs)
- Don't look at me.
- Melvin I have to
de-vein the shrimp.
- If I had a nickel for
every time I've heard that all right.
- (laughs)
- Now listen, I'm going
to count down ready.
Beep, beep, beep, there's a monster
in the living room. So that's it.
(crowd cheers)
- So randomly enough, I walked in and
watched my daughter, she's five,
and I let her just pick
something on Netflix,
I was doing something, and all of a sudden
I'm like, why are they speaking Spanish?
She watches things that are from Spain,
but they'll try and do them in English,
like half the episode is English,
they do that a lot still.
- Yes, part of the problem is in different
languages there are different cadences,
and different rhythms, so that's why
if you watch a lot of old movies you'll
hear people talking,
like this, over there.
Because they're trying to
- (laughs)
- fit in dialogue into
foreign mouth flapping.
- Oh my god, that's hard! And
hard not to laugh, obviously!
- It's hard not to laugh?
- Mhm.
- You need practice.
- I know, I know, you know
what, I should just steer clear.
- Forget it.
- I feel like I should forget it.
- You're doing too much already.
- (laughs) So you developed another
vocal skill, what is it?
- I can do a cricket.
- A cricket? What were you in
Pinocchio or something?
(crowd laughs)
How did you develop a cricket sound?
- Well because there was a guy on "Wings,"
one of the techs, one of the grips,
named Mundo, and he used to very kind of
secretly throw in a cricket sound,
and it would drive the
sound people insane.
- (gasps) I love him.
- So I have to just wet my whistle.
- (mumbles)
- (cricket sound)
- That is impressive!
- Is it?
(crowd cheers)
(crowd applauds)
- That's impressive!
- (laughs) You need to calm down.